pour aller jusqu'au bout de leurs idées
les syndicats ont invité une délégation
de ji et de safran à découvrir les
ateliers et le savoir-faire belfortain
le but les convaincre qu'ils peuvent
ensemble fabriquer des pièces pour
l'aéronautique non identifiés qu'on
était sur une opportunité unique parce
qu'on avait donc déjà des usines
construites près ati a accusé activités
qu'on avait donc un parc machines qui
était compatible avec quelques
modifications mais surtout que nous
avons des compétences rares
safran est un équipementier
incontournable dans l'aéronautique
general electric avant 1999 tabriquet
aussi des pièces pour l'aviation
aujourd'hui ce secteur est en plein
essor 4 % de croissance en plus par an
selon les prévisions grâce à ce
rapprochement
j pourrait ainsi reprendre leurs
activités d'autrefois et maintenir
l'emploi sur ses sites de belfort et de
bourogne ce qu'on fabrique pour une
turbine à gaz
la grosse valeur ajoutée va être la même
pour un moteur d'avion
donc la réponse est ce qu'on sait faire
un moteur d'avion oui il n'ya pas de
freins techniques
malheureusement cette proposition
ambitieuse n'est pas du goût de safran
ce rapprochement est peu envisageable
regard de la formation du personnel et
des ateliers de production
l'investissement serait trop lourd quant
au ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
il y encore trois semaines n'étaient pas
convaincus je soutiendrai les projets de
diversification néanmoins un tel projet
nécessite des investissements lourds
pour adapter l'outil industriel
mais la pression des élus locaux qui
soutiennent les syndicats semble porter
ses fruits
le sénateur martial bourquin on va ainsi
rencontrer bruno le maire damien meslot
lui a déjà obtenu un retour
nous avons un petit peu fait pression et
bruno le maire nous a informés il ya 48
heures qu'il avait obtenu de safran et
de general electric qui nomme des
référents aviation de façon à pouvoir
étudier cette proposition et voir le
coût de sa mise en oeuvre
damien meslot a reçu les syndicats de ji
en fin d'après midi
demain c'est au tour de la présidente de
région de bourgogne franche comté de les
rencontrer